الازمه في السودان موجه هجره جديده صحيفه
تيليغرافي البريطانيه تتوقع نزوح اعداد
مهوله من السكان وبالتالي زياده في عدد
المهاجرين غير النظاميين
فبريطانيا وحدها قد تشهد لجوء اعداد كبيره
من السودانيين الامم المتحده تقول ان عددا
كبيرا من اللاجئين السودانيين فروا الى
بلدان المجاوره منذ بدء الازمه مع توقعات
بنزوح مئه الف سوداني الى تشاد ومئه
وسبعين الفا الى جنوب السودان بالاضافه
الى مصر وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
[موسيقى]
بدورها تناشد الامم المتحده جميع الدول
بجوار السودان ابقاء حدودها مفتوحه امام
الذين يبحثون عن الاماني والحمايه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات